you know my policy on covet guys and
it's it's tough to hold to this policy
it's a reuben report policy and i try to
uh go by the policies that i uh set
forth here at the reuben report my
policy is i don't want to put out the uh
the stories about kova that are going to
depress you because it's just like we
just have to move on and i think in most
cases most of you guys have moved on i
have moved on i don't wear a mask
anywhere you've got to live your life
get injected 80 times whatever you want
to do like make some decisions for
yourself this [ __ ] ain't going away they
love the power they want more control
over your life okay we all get it well
there's this guy bill de blasio and he's
he's a true psychopath horrible mayor of
new york city destroyed new york city to
the point that my family i've mentioned
this many times before there were times
since around 1910 that my family had
probably at the height of it about 60 to
70 family members living in new york
city in the boroughs we got two left i
used to say there was one but i did
i was informed of a cousin in brooklyn i
got one in manhattan one in brooklyn
everyone else has fled my sister was the
last one to flee with her husband and
two kids during the pandemic the city is
dirty it's gross it smells like weed
crime is through the roof you can break
into stories and steals [ __ ] we all know
that you can just go into cvs and just
clear out an aisle nobody's going to do
anything it's really really depressing
it just it just is he ruined the
greatest city on earth that's what bill
de blasio did and you know hopefully
it'll come back at some point but
anyway the guy's got about three weeks
left of his uh his terrible
administration and uh listen to what
he's doing with his last couple weeks we
in new york city have decided to
use a preemptive strike to really do
something bold to stop the further
growth of covet and the dangers it's
causing to all of us so
as of today we're going to announce a
first in the nation measure our health
commissioner will announce a vaccine
mandate for private sector employers
across the board
all private sector employers in new york
city will be covered by this vaccine
mandate as of december 27th we're going
to have some other measures as well to
really focus on maximizing vaccination
quickly
so we can get ahead of omicron and all
the other challenges we're facing right
now
okay so you get it he's a fear-mongering
maniac a head of omicron okay there's
about three people in the united states
with omicron which from what i'm told is
no relation to unicron the planet-eating
destroyer uh from the transformers movie
in 1985 way better than any of the
michael bay transformers movies by the
way
um he's a maniac he is a complete maniac
so what is the part of this that is the
positive part well first the positive
part is he's leaving right this guy has
a couple weeks left and he's going out
in what he views i suppose as a blaze of
glory this is a guy who and he had
locked everybody down and said don't go
to the gyms he was caught at the gym he
was caught in the park i mean he's just
he's just a horrible human being like
that's all i can say about these people
at this point like what else is there to
say about all of these people i i don't
know but the silver lining is this
new yorkers um and i was there a couple
weeks ago and i spent most of my adult
life living in new york city i was i
moved to new york city right out of
college about 2000. i lived in new york
city until about 2013 when i moved to
this crazy dystopia of los angeles i
really should have my head examined but
new yorkers have a sense of fight and a
sense of spirit if you if you haven't uh
watched the ghostbusters the original
ghostbusters movie or ghostbusters two
even you can really feel it in
ghostbusters if you don't believe me
that's new yorkers still have that when
i was there a few weeks ago you could
still feel that on the streets and i
think people have had it with this
[ __ ] i really do and i think a lot
of people are just going to say no no
i'm not complying i will not comply i am
not listening to you you are a crazy
communist nut bag you're on your way out
you people do not own our lives we
elected you
to well we elected you or we didn't vote
for you but somebody elected you to to
defend our rights not have you rule over
us like kings and queens and you're
horrible people and we're just not going
to do it and by the way when i was in
new york city that was when you had to
show the passports and all that and
nowhere was i asked to put uh to show a
passport i went into places without
masks and all that so the the silver
lining is that the more they get
hysterical and that's what these idiots
are doing they are making omicron into
the next delta and there will be
something after that and something after
that and they will never they will never
look at themselves right they'll never
take that mirror de blasio said it right
there two years into this thing well
wait a minute two years into this thing
who was the mayor for two years it was
you you douchebag so maybe you should be
looking at your policies if it's so bad
and stepping down in shame rather than
pushing more draconian laws
but this has nothing to do with a virus
anymore as you know this is about crazy
people who want to control your life and
it will be your job
on this planet earth to make sure that
they do not control you so the positive
twist again in case you missed it there
the positive twist is that people will
just ignore it i really think that will
happen even here in this ridiculous
place known as los angeles i see people
starting to ignore it people will just
ignore these people they will keep
coming out with more ridiculous you know
it's almost
you hear this out of communist regimes
that the the rhetoric keeps getting
ramped up and ramped up and ramped up
because they know they don't have the
people so they just have to keep seeming
like it's the show must go on you know i
talk about kayfabe a lot which is which
is wwe it's wrestling that we're all
watching this thing that we know isn't
true but we're all participating in you
can have real emotions as hulk hogan
slams andre the giant and you can be
like oh my god hogan beat andre the
giant and you have this feeling like oh
my god that just happened in front of me
and it's real even though they set the
whole thing up beforehand and that's
sort of what we're in right now we're in
the show must go on version of democracy
with these clowns and i think more and
more people will just ignore it and go
about their lives
and
and i i don't know beyond that i think
we still got a lot to fight but that
that's the hope the hope is that you're
the hope
and prove me right would you do me a
favor prove dave right